Draw an uneven line on your cheek or any other place on your face or body.
Once you have done this, add more color to your uneven line.
As a result, you would need to have a base of your planned scar.
Now, move on to the scarring liquid which is called rigid collodion.
When you apply rigid collodion unto the skin,...
...it dries out and as a result, it tenses up the skin...
...and thus visually creates the effect of the scar.
Apply the product in multiple layers and let it dry a minute in between.
Now, the next step is to remove some shine that the dried product has on your skin.
All you need to do is set your scar with some powder...
...and then on top, add some concealer.
Finally, to give your scar the appearance of the new injury,...
...as if it is still healing, add some pink lipstick or lip gloss on top.
Blend it with your fingers for a more realistic look.
And here's the final result.